now there is specific evidence of fraud
in in certain cases not even just at the
presidential level
in one congressional race in new york
involving a congressional candidate i
actually know personally
the two candidates the democratic
incumbent and the republican challenger
are separated by 12 votes
i want to talk about your vote mattering
want to talk about uh going out there
even if it's a system that's
vulnerable to fraud so new york's 22nd
congressional district you've got the
republican claudia tenney
has a 12-vote lead over the democratic
incumbent anthony brindesi and
that's good news right because that
means claudia's going to win the
republican's going to win we're all good
oh it's been it's been almost a month
now since
the elections i think we should be able
to count our ballots by now
we'll talk about a tin pot dictatorship
we can't even count our ballots within a
month
well no we have to keep counting the
ballots until the democrat wins
claudia has a 12 vote lead well guess
what conveniently
they just found a batch of 55 ballots
they were hidden i don't know where they
were they were underneath the mail truck
or something
they just found this batch the uh
chenango county attorney alan gordon
said that election officials
determined that of these 55 ballots
found 44 of them are valid
now the other way to read that is 11 of
these votes
were fraudulent were ineligible
how'd they end up there so 44 are valid
44 could
swing an election easily if the election
is right now
hanging by 12 votes so
this county attorney has advised the
board of elections to secure the ballots
leave them unopened in their offices and
obviously throw out the ones that are
illegitimate but now 44 ballots
i hope they're unopened i hope that
their legitimate ballots i hope
that they weren't just being held in
case they were needed by the democrats
but when the votes trickle in and
trickle in and trickle in
until the democrats win that that does
not give us confidence in the system